- So, there's a huge
obsession with pimple popping.
For some it's actually more
satisfying than disgusting
to watch someone bust a zit.
It's even a whole thing on reality TV.
Where, where should we draw the line?
Where do you think?
Go David.
- Well, I never watch TV and go,
"I wish there was more pus and drainage.
(audience laughing)
"Why can't they work it into the show?
And it's so gross.
I'm in the, like, lobby at Jiffy Lube
at 10 a.m they're playing it,
and I'm like, "I think it's a bit early
for Doctor Pimple Popper.
- How do you feel, Fortune?
- I don't understand, like, okay,
a small like pimple, all right,
you're just like boop
okay, that felt good.
But when you go to these,
on these shows or YouTube
and you see when, like,
this giant thing comes out,
you know I'm talking about, it's like--
- Yes I do.
- It's like a jello shot coming out
of someone's back--
- [Kelly] Yes!
- [David] She loves it.
- I love it!
- Disgusting!
What are you doing that you
have a jello shot in your back?
Why?
- You got a hot water bottle on your back.
- [Kelly] Things collect.
- You got to shower.
- Things collect, that is not it--
- [David] Things collect.
- People can still shower
and it still happens,
I'm just saying it's--
- But what is that?
- It's it's it's dirt and grime and goo.
- They really let, people let it go.
- They do, okay okay, what do you think?
- Oh I love em--
- [Kelly] I love em!
- I'm with you Kelly--
- [Kelly] I love it!
- Yes.
- I could watch it all day.
- I hope it just takes off.
It's finally a job market
my 16-year-old son can corner.
(audience, guests, Kelly laughing)
- That's what I want,
him just making videos
of him playing fortnight
and popping pimples and
making us millions of dollars.
- Yeah, that's a little niche market.
But you know what it's
a gateway gross show.
Because now there's My
Feet Are Killing Me,
and that is--
- [Kelly] What's that?
- It's like--
- Uh, in the South it's
called My Dogs Are Barking.
(guests laughing)
- That's just, first of
all, they unroll the sock,
and that's the first 10
minutes, it's like drum roll,
and then they pull it and it's boils,
and, they look like
trees, some of these feet.
It's so gross.
Yeah, I don't know how it gets--
- That's a TV show for real?
- [David] Yeah.
- I've never, I've never seen it.
- I would watch it, I'm just saying.
- Yeah, it's sickening.
- I love all that gross stuff,
I don't know what's wrong with me.
- It's a good diet because you watch it
and then you barf for 20 minutes.
- This is where we could,
we're, we're so different.
I could be eating Oreos being
fine with watching that.
(audience, guests laughing)